um
we start off with apologies for absence
i know
that counseling
we're okay at the moment
right item two
minutes of the cnr meeting
which are on your agenda over the 28th
of june
chaired
[Music]
working from the bottom page three
four five
six
seven
[Music]
or happy with that's requested i'm happy
with the minutes can i just ask a
question about one of the
items yes well let's uh
uh can we have a vote that i can sign
those minutes please
those in favor
[Music]
that is unanimous thank you now your
question
yeah on page five i raised this issue
about more february
road to recovery about house prices now
we've got a right to rnp
and we actually
okay
so the question is was jeffrey cox
contacted has he responded i think it's
the answer isn't
it okay no he hasn't been contacted yet
but we have a meeting shed shield with
him
next week for the week after that yeah
and we were raised
with that that's acceptable committee
okay perhaps everything's been written
to
[Music]
eye is not the bible look at his
register of interest
on the elementary website
um no other comment on the minutes will
move
to items three the action list
any comments there on
i'm sure dealing with that right thank
you yes i can update that one
as part of the borough center project we
bought a container that's been sitting
down on
wilkes field car park the plan is
to bring that to the back carpark
riverbank house
store there because we're short storage
space and we'll use it from there
we've made planning applications for its
uh relocation and we were informed by
the planning team we didn't need
planning permission for it to be done
its development to the application
next item five
forward plan you see there are any
comments there too
i do have an extra item if possible to
add for september is a recommendation
from the
armour board in relation to a bond for
the fresh spring they discussed it at
the last half of all meetings
as i understand it and i think they'll
be coming forward
24th of january meeting probably public
toilets what's happening here
it's your award well um yeah in terms of
lenders um probably are
waiting for response
[Music]
that's right so so chad i asked tom
phillips to give us an idea with these
leases because there was a big lump of
polices and
sitting and just moving backwards in the
schedule um
these are the leases of god where we
think they'll come to you for a decision
okay we go
right we move on agenda item
six
declarations of interest you're all
adults i'm not gonna go through that one
item seven it's not suggested to be any
part two
items item eight urgent matters
i've got no urgent practice
additional restrictions ground business
support in northern
pages 10 to 15.
[Music]
thank you just to give you some
background
about the report um we've had allocated
discounts of 3.8 million thousand
discretionary business support
grant funding from the government and we
received
maybe about a month ago in july the last
tranche of 619 thousand which
was fully spent originally 3.2 million
just so your members aware this is in
addition to what i'd call probably the
mandated business support grants
which pertain to businesses eligibility
based on their business rates
so this is discretionary support and it
originally came in that some businesses
didn't get business support grants for
various reasons like they were business
rate payers
businesses operating home or perhaps
where an industry wasn't mandated to
close up
the food processing business but the
main customer base of them
was the leisure sector in terms of pubs
and restaurants and therefore they were
adversely effective so on the last
trance of funding that we've got 619 000
pounds and we've not really started
we're just about to that's utilizing
that money
the government has given us the option
to and
whilst they expect the majority of the
funding to go directly to business
they're giving us the option to
hold some of the money back to do
business focused business support
and north devon plus they um a partner
organisation of the council
in conjunction with norfolk council
they've actually administered all the
discretionary
business grants to date and what the
proposal is that we touch lice 100 000
pounds
of the last trench of discretion grant
from the 619 thousand pounds to allow
them
to offer business support advice and
guidance and that's where the
recommendation is
hoping for myself or shawn to take any
questions on that recommendation
so just so you were in the district
specially granted 3.9 million
the actual other mandated business
programs they've amounted to that
partisan
house
right uh yes
yes
so just to make it clear no devon cancer
will be issued
advice not cashed not them
plus and not democrats yes business
advice
the government has given us this money
to distribute to businesses
and yet we're giving it to north david
bus to distribute advice
and right with top slicing 100 000
pounds the government has said
we can do this this is except for what
they accept they said well they expected
majority to go directly to businesses
but they have the facility for councils
to
top slice the money to do as they
cleaned in terms of
how they support businesses
to be honest the businesses with further
money
rather than voice and we've had problems
with north end plus before we've queried
some of their
expenses
[Music]
i would concur what country christie
said i would have thought businesses
need more
support they can they need cash nowadays
more than advice
you know i can see you know a hundred
thousand from us hundred thousand
from north devon it's going to pay off
time there's going to be a lot of
expense incurring in
delivering that 200 000 advice the money
in my opinion should go
straight to the businesses wherever
possible steve
uh it's going to uh i guess respond to
council must be the
200 000 is for the provision of the time
for the officers to spend
giving that advice to businesses
um it's kind of regarded as some an
additional
support to the wider business community
for those businesses who don't actually
are not entitled to get the cash so not
every business will be able to
access cash some won't be able to as
this is seen as a
wider breadth of support to capture
a wider set of the business community
across
northern denver and that's that's the
purpose behind it
i suppose in perspective as well it's
100 000 pounds out of 3.8 million
you know so three point seven million
three point eight million will be
directly
going into businesses after three point
two million directors suggested you
where
three point two millions or even spent
every penny that went direct to the
businesses that we absorbed
the costs of administrating that uh from
north devon plus
either council through its new burdens
funding that develop those costs
council unlocked yeah i mean what
if you know if we put in a hundred
thousand pounds would that be ring fence
just for
tourist businesses or could someone come
in and use the whole rocks
in the type of businesses of tourist
businesses
so that would be written thanks justin
torridge yes drift across the board
no chancellor bush man
thank you general i know two individuals
that work in the entertainment
industry locally that clearly they've
been
dramatically hit because there hasn't
been any functions
except the peer houses have venue as an
example
they've been shut down virtually for the
year yeah and this person has applied
to torridge on a couple of occasions to
try and get some support some help
and clearly isn't eligible so you know
what if i accept you know a hundred
thousand pounds is a
relatively small amount of total sum
he's not eligible to apply given them a
hundred thousand times to give him
advice
advice will be well you're not eligible
so you know
they need cash they don't necessarily
need you know the help and advice
necessarily project chairs is not
advised to tell if they're not eligible
as advice
to get them um some businesses started
so some businesses will need advice to
support
uh putting business plans together
support discussions with
the banks and that kind of advice so
it's wider than
just the grand scheme itself um
north devon put in 100 000 as well so
we're kind of
matching what they're doing so we've got
a complete
kind of set of uh help of the support or
businesses
across northern devon it's something
that was included in your
uh northern recovery prospectus which
was approved
the last cnr meeting i think so it's
kind of kind of
widely recognized that businesses need
more support
than simply a cash injection to help
them
so it sounds like we're going to be
shooting ourselves in the foot if we
don't match what north devon are
are offering is that what you're
suggesting i i'm not suggesting i'm
saying north devon have done it it's up
to committee members to determine
uh what you want to do which north
denver already committed
to that
councilor hanson first of all mr
chairman apologies for being late
you were incredibly prompt uh i
obviously didn't melt the steps quickly
enough
to get um but my comment on this
is that we all recognize that a lot of
businesses have had to
consider their business plans have had
to diversify
have had to seek new markets have had to
look at the way they trade on the
increased dominance of the online
tools for marketing products
and looking at their way they engage
with their workforce
so i think um a hundred thousand
to help companies who may not have that
expertise
and may not have a clear vision of all
the opportunities that there are there
for them um to issue them with guidance
i agree in some respect with cancer i
have
have empathy with councillor bushby's
comments about
some people really needing the cash
but i think this on a bigger picture on
a bigger front to actually
help stimulate the restart of businesses
that may have really struggled
um is is well worth the hundred thousand
for this
uh council to support them so i would
like to move the recommendation
is there a secondary counselor lock
counselor christine just asked another
question um
we were told some time ago the
government was querying some of the
payments we made that might be
they might be claiming them back or
making
first off it doesn't relate to the
discretionary business support grants it
relates to what i'd call the mandated
patch which were based on business rates
naturally meeting space and i and the
legal team had a meeting on
i think it was wednesday and we're just
pulling the papers together
at the point where basically correctly
the wrong stacy would essentially hand
over our case files
to the department of business and say
this is where we are this is the steps
we've taken to do the recovery
and the letters we've written
essentially over to you
so until the case files are handed over
to them we wouldn't know
this is in policy do you know how much
money is involved and i think it's about
330 thousand pounds
torres might have to pay you that in the
worst case scenario it's the worst
listener i mean
basically all through the process and
the public business and enterprise is
that they stand behind councils
they recognize that you know there's a
potential for fraudulent applications
etc and they would stand behind us and
cover the costs
then there's been an occasional
correspondence which is
where they've looked at the actions that
we've taken and said you know they've
made some vague
that's the same it works but which
eventually says things along the lines
of
we'd have to see if we acted reasonably
okay so it's kind of mixed messages if
i'm being perfectly honest
but there's lots of correspondence where
they stand behind councils and say that
they
back us in terms of financial they
realize that we're doing it on their
heart but obviously i i'm not privy to
their
discussions
yeah would that affect our um surplus
budget then it's coming up later as
another
gender item because we mentioned that no
we've not made any assumptions that
we'll be paying that money back
so our surplus assumes that and we will
not be repaying the departments of
businesses
industry
and curiosity have you looked at it oh
my god we are only
[Music]
i've below got insights of their their
thought process but i i would suspect
nationally this figure will foul dwarf
the figure that scientologists have for
the
instance of genuine traffickation fraud
that would have taken place
uh i've heard different things in the
pages that maybe even runs into like
close to a billion so i suspect the the
impact on councils from down the country
could be quite large so um
i think a political hot potato if the
department of business at some point
said that council had to be liable for
it but like i said myself steve none was
a
privy to the inner world workings of the
department
um yeah just to come back on
this actual um support from north seven
plus the way i met it was that
um actually that scheme in itself you
could bid into for grant
funding for websites and um
ways to boost your business other than
just advice
is that right yes that's correct but in
terms of advice
who at north7 plus is qualified to give
the advice
so there are as far as i'm aware you
often
have three steady accredited business
advisors
and then there's a couple of people that
support
[Music]
all right proposed and
seconded i believe
no other proposals i'm going to put it
to the vote
those in favor please show
[Music]
um
six against
one abstain myself
two two abstentions
okay
[Music]
item 10 refugee resettlement afghan
relocation scheme
ages 16 to 19 janet in charge
thank you um in march 2020 members
approved this authority's participation
in the
syrian vulnerable persons relocation
scheme
this scheme is coordinated across them
by the county council who will work with
local organizations and participate in
local authorities
to ensure that the necessary necessary
support is put in place for those
refugee families placed with them
members at that time resolved that we
would participate in this program
and would provide support to two refugee
families
entering the scheme and placed
intolerage and this would cover one
family in each of the two years of the
scheme
uh the report from you also mentions a
parallel refugee support scheme that
also exists
something called community sponsorship
under this scheme sponsoring
organisations such as a charity takes on
the role of receiving
and supporting the family into the
community through that we've had two
syrian families successfully placed in
biddeford managed in this area by a
charity
called target community sponsorship so
we do already have experience
of successfully supporting families into
our communities
so just after members resolved to
participate in the relocation scheme
a virus hit and the program was
suspended by the uk government therefore
we've not been able to progress
this commitment this scheme was only
just reopened so the first matter for
members to consider today is whether you
are happy
to extend commitment made last year a
further year
so that support be given to two families
to be placed in 2021
and 2022 as opposed to 2020
and 2021 resolved last year
the second matter for consideration by
members today relates to an issue i'm
sure you've seen in the news recently
the government have written to all local
authorities asking for urgent support to
the africa for the afghan locally
employed
staff relocation scheme it's recognized
that afghans who supported and worked
with uk troops in roles such as
interpreters there were increased risk
of intimidation
and danger in that country recent events
in afghanistan have increased this risk
and the government is looking for
support to
relocate these families to the uk this
is very similar but not identical to the
vulnerable person scheme however
it essentially involves the integration
and support of the relocated families
into the community
and this is supported by a financial
package dependent on the size
and the needs of the families concerned
so the second
question before members this morning is
whether we include this afghan
relocation scheme within the offer
we have previously made so that families
giving refuge and support and storage
over this two-year period can come
through either the syrian
or afghan schemes the democrats council
apparently looked to procure the
reception support service provided
across northern devon
and the charitable organisation already
involved in community sponsorship has
been approached
to provide this service however the two
schemes
are different and the procurement of the
support service will need to be run in
parallel so
then county council have asked us to
clarify whether we will be willing to
support both schemes
or remain just with the syrian
relocation scheme
so that's the two matters before members
this morning and i'm happy to take more
questions
all right councillor any idea where we
would host any families that we
take into tour no the discussions that
we've had
with the community organisation
organisation concern
and they've indicated that they are um
positive that we'll be able to find
landlords community-minded landlords
who'd be willing
to take families from these schemes
but we can't see where that will because
that that hasn't actually started yet
but they are confident that they have
people who will be willing to support
the schools
can anyone give me an update on the
number of
local people that we've currently got
that are on the housing list
that can't get a property
i ask the question because if not if i
was a local person
and i'd been waiting for several years
for property
i wouldn't be too happy if um you know
someone
from overseas was able to leapfrog uh
the queue
and actually you know get a property uh
let's
understand council rushford um it is i
don't have the exact number i can get
that number for you it is
the hundreds several hundreds okay
[Music]
okay we'll take thanks to james first
well well we just came last year at cnr
and what we're doing is rolling it over
on the um
referendum uh sound one because
obviously you couldn't do it last year
and obviously we have a certain
obligation to the african
um relocation scheme so i'm happy to
support
both motion recommendations
thank you chancellor yes thank you chair
um
i echo council bush's concerns
um and i also follow a council james
said we do have obligations to the
afghan
people who work with the british forces
in afghanistan
i fully support carrying over the scheme
that was agreed last year because
obviously it's been held in advance
but again my concern is there's a group
now
we've all had the email from the meeting
second september
crisis in torridge and elsewhere about
housing
i'm just concerned as to where a house
or a couple of houses would come to
house
the extra people coming in i've got
nothing against doing that
but local people will not be very happy
it
reading always details on facebook about
the um
the stories about how people cannot find
properties and thrown out their problems
etc
it's getting worse so that would be my
concern
i've got a problem with housing refugees
if there are properties available
which at this time they don't appear to
be that's that's my only concern
sure i could just come in the the
charity concern is
confident that they can source those two
properties
um they have had experience of doing
this in the past and
their marketing or however they do that
has been successful
previously and i believe it will be
again okay can i come back on actually
i mean i can understand the charity
being you know confident we can do that
but
how is that going to be put across the
people out there who cannot
source anyway and that's my concern i
don't have a problem with the charity
sourcing properties but
if i couldn't find a house i'd say well
how come
you can you've got the resources to find
a property
when i can't do it you know that is my
concern
regarding regard to this proposal
well somebody who's involved in
providing housing
i don't believe that the two is going to
make a great difference i can understand
the psychological effect
but it's not going to do it and i've
spoken to steve this morning they're
trying to get to columbia this week
trying to look at what they're doing in
temporary hosting um
i've actually got personal issues with
um an empty belly but
uh that's nothing to do with council um
i i honestly
just think that we need to do what we
we're committed to
and it's a moral issue and if we don't
stand by that
i'm also improving the housing strong
and doing something
voting and i've been for a long long
time but i don't believe
um people are going to get that agitated
about
we're doing something that we should be
doing for two houses
i'm sorry chancellor chris
well when we had this before when i
think it was syrian refugees
um the british trust we actually we were
approached we were asked for a place and
they were going to take it up
but then i think one of the members of
the charity actually made their own
premises available i think that's what
was that what happened
so these might be new premises coming on
the market as it were
we do have moral duty to do this and i
think we're looking at it the wrong way
around
we all know there's a housing crisis in
torrh but why is that
what are we doing about second homes
what are we doing about holiday homes
what are we doing about affordable homes
this is the problem you know it's not
it's not an intractable problem but
tories really need to take hold of it
and say look this is what we need to do
now
rather than say oh we can't take any
more there are enough houses for
everyone
it's just that some people often
unfortunately it's a national problem we
are dead right what you said but that it
was fascinating last night about radio 4
until 12 parliamentary program and it's
a national
problem but there we are
yes um i'd just say that i believe i'm
saying that um the syrian
people that were rehoused the children
go to
my daughter's school actually and it's
been a massive success
and i think that
in terms of the housing issue that we
have some
of the problem is the
type of housing that we have not the
fact that we don't
always have the houses available but
sometimes we don't have the houses
of the correct size available or we have
people
living in houses that actually
they really should move out of and
release for families
if there's a there's a whole bigger
issue as i
understand it within our housing crisis
and within
those that are rented within rented
accommodation
in that you know if everyone was in a
house applicable to the size they needed
perhaps the issue wouldn't be so bad but
that doesn't happen
um so there's a wealth of problems
associated with our housing crisis
and i really can care with councillor
james we can't see that two
houses um you know is going to make a
massive difference to our formulation
and i really i actually think
that you're um not giving the residents
of torridge enough credit because i
think that
a lot of the residents would actually be
um in favor of supporting refugees
and i think we're living in a time
that's very different at the moment from
when it has been in the past and the
outlook amongst
people is very different to what it's
been so i think you need to
can we sign up to the armed forces
covenant where we agreed
that members of the armed forces would
get preferential treatment
is that still in place yeah that that is
in place we
are going to be updating um that shortly
so that will be a future
uh report to members because that scheme
has been revised and updated so
yes we did sign up to it previously it's
it's kind of
um it's a little bit outdated now but we
will be coming to members shortly
by the end of the year and to update our
commitment
so you could actually argue that these
afghan refugees who work with our forces
are actually almost
falling under that agreement
thanks for appreciating just like to
clarify my position
i have no problem with housing refugees
from
areas of conflict around the world
particularly where we've
um you know had a military
and i'd be presence to do that
particularly if we had
a capacity to do that you know
unfortunately you know
we're in a situation where betty ford
i think after 10 counts of the next 10
council agenda there is a motion being
put forward
to declare torridge a housing emergency
um quite how far that's going to go i
don't know but clearly we have
a big problem with hundreds of hundreds
of individuals
and some families that urgently need
housing and as countries as you said you
know it's
the big picture is that there is this
national
emergency in we have certainly got our
fair share of it in george
i'd be delighted to house them if you
had some word you know somewhere to book
them
but i can't see it morally right that
you're
denying someone local a family home
over and above you know someone that's
coming in from abroad
however however dire the situation is
right well it's proposed and set up
councillor hudson
sorry i i've waited till i'm in full
support
of offering
housing to both and continuing
to support the syrian families and to
extending into afghan relocation
what i would like clarity on is because
i
i did read an awful lot about this when
the first proposals came out
with regard to the financial support
that
we will be undertaking as well as the
housing provision
because it is different to that which is
afforded to syrian families
and i feel that if we're making this
decision today which i'm
in total support of we need to do it
with the full
information or as much as is possible
to make an informed decision about the
financial ramifications for this council
and i take it that in the second
recommendation
we're subject to the necessary risk
mitigation measures being put in place
and agreed
through the devin resettlement group in
agreement with our section 151
that relates to the financial issues
that's correct the reason for that is
that the um
financial situation without the afghan
speech is still in the
discussion and consideration and so even
the
county council are wary of
um progressing mountains and worlds
matters are
resolved so the the
scheme when it first started that
support of the afghan
families was only available for four
years local authorities were consulted
widely on that
that's been extended to 12 months and
there's still some details that are
being finalized which is the reason for
that
that recommendation that we consider
risk before finally signing up to
the afghan scheme right so this is a
in recommendation that we agree the
principle of
the accommodation subject to
the financial implications as prescribed
by devon county council
i would be brought back to this group
for a final decision
i've put in the report that that would
be subject to um review by
section 151 officer uh purely for
matters of speed
because the government are trying to get
these individuals relocated
as soon as possible um but i just didn't
have that
that final financial information and
risk information is going to work
so that they still definitely county
councils still haven't determined this
and correct me if i'm wrong you said
it's been extended you said
four years but it was four months to
four months
to two to twelve months
yeah the record yeah yes um
i think i trust i think there is very
concern
amongst my colleagues in other districts
that this hasn't been finalized by devon
county council
do we have any indication of how long
this will take
and as i say the government is really
pushing these families
already yes and then temporary
accommodation across the country at the
moment
and so that hopefully it should be
resolved shortly by
by the county council i believe that's a
decision that's
uh going to their members very shortly
so i need to have any insight into this
or what i'll
out as to the county's decision within
processes
the leader and i meet with daven county
council
chief executive on a regular basis but
it's
not only subject to a recent discussion
that's trying to say something that's
kind of
changing day by day
[Music]
and and hypothetically if a family did
not
meet their presidential test what would
happen um
that is one of the matters and that's
that's uh causing some contention at the
moment because while the dwp
said that that should be um sorted
within three months
there have been occasions where it's
taken longer than that
and the it essentially leaves the family
in limbo and that they're unable to
gain benefits or seek
employment because they failed that test
and this is a matter for me for the dwp
to
resolve and that's one of the the issues
that is being discussed
um regionally nationally and at the
moment to
to try and then bring the dwp guidance
in line with the
the expectations
[Music]
what would happen if they did fail uh
as i say they essentially left in limbo
they
they're accepted they can't be sent back
because of the risks that have been
accepted
and so they've got their status in the
uk it just means that they can't
seek legal employment and in the uk
until that residency test is sorted
right well i've got a proposal i'm
looking for a second
to accept the recommendations number
five
is there a second left
potential change that
[Music]
eight those against
one abstaining that's it
now we come to a gender item in level
an unusual one is a government
a budget surplus
normally it's overspent and where's the
money coming
from if you don't
[Music]
okay so just um just explain how we
arrived at the resurface that
we're proposing to set aside for leisure
um 2000 2021 was a unique
financial year and the council
had unprecedented pressures and must
increment expense versus all those
various blue
bars there so like the biggest one we
had was council tax and business rates
in terms of
our collection rate reduced in both of
them areas
car parking and particularly the first
three months of the lockdown could have
been april may june 2020
and ongoing support we go into the
leisure throughout the mostly closed
throughout
2021 and there is other coded related
pressures such as ppe
i.t to facilitate homework majority of
our office-based staff
over the other side effects such as
interest rates
plummeted at the start of the pandemic
from 0.1
which is the return we're getting now in
our investments and we
our hostile income was less than uh we
expected really because the building
trade
um in april and june was
inactive so the hospital came on the
street later and also for the social
distance and we couldn't get the
same revenue than we could so the big
figure in yellow there
chocolate says about 1.7 million worth
of
pressure so could move on to the next
line
however thankfully well we would be
bankrupt government recognized that
it was unique and yeah they gave us
various amounts of
covered granting i think it was just
under 1.2 million just general support
grant
that wasn't particularly based on based
on the size of the organizer the council
but basically
the general code into program we also
got 295 000 pounds for lost fees and
charges which
predominantly is compensated for our
lost car parking in the first three
months of april may and june
2024 ongoing some lost car back in that
town centers
and we've got 392 thousand pounds
we're cold with new villains that's
recognizing like i said we spent over 42
hours on distributing new virgins grant
and the discretion grants of
3.2 million so we've got monies from the
central country for doing that
and they gave us some other funding as
well and in the name
we absorbed all extra work internally at
some would be all the time and
competitive officer went full-time from
part-time
but in the main we didn't go out and
employ additional staff to deliver the
work
it developed on predominantly the
business strength team and the
finance team and some extend the it team
as well
so insult we've got 1.974 million being
called
related grants and that's right
and then it wasn't all about coping
there was other factors so we had some
favorable variances staffing and
training 614
000 when i say planning and building
control i'm really saying planning with
the longest income
we've had an unprecedented year in terms
of planning application income
uh various refuge related things such as
we increased our recycling rate um
guarding waste results our recycling
credits and costco
and various other things so basically
we've got about 1.5 million pounds
in non-corvid related um just so
for information and the staff related to
spending about six percent of the total
staff and related budgets
and there was a bit of a hiatus on
recruitment just at the start of the
lobbyists that maybe is a
contradictivity factor
but the next slide please talk
so we've already a previous committees
set aside 642 thousand pounds to
the capital fundings we have a deficit
on our capital funding and we've went
for quite torturous
uh meetings of our family reached the
gap on our capital funding
so we agreed to agree with 642 000 aside
to bridge that gap on our capital
funding and we set other monies aside to
reserve such as a backlog maintenance
reserve
etc so that leaves us with 771 000 that
we can set aside to contribute to
leisure we know that we've got a backlog
of maintenance issues in our leisure
and obviously we've got to roll forward
a different model for
delivering leisure which won't be from
an outsourced contract
model so just in summary
while some in the report says look the
recommendation to set aside a circle of
771 000
in reality which puts in aside just
under 1.7 million pounds has been
brought side to reserve
is essentially the surplus for the year
so i don't know if i've got another
slide on that one
okay so just some of the highlights um
it's been an unusual year normally make
about 6 000 payments a year
well that's nearly 17 000 pounds 17 000
payments we've now made
um we use our gold annual spend
excluding housing benefit 16 million
it's nearly 61 million in 2020 21.
and that's why at this time i'm just if
anybody's got any questions after
hopefully i'll answer them
unusual situation i hope that um
none of our treasures departments are on
a sort of commission on
turnover i don't like the idea of that
um right general discussion please
cancel change well i'm happy with the
report i'm happy with the decision
and i think you know we're going into
our
one side for the left of the server
thank you thank you good morning to
everybody
this is a huge amount of money well over
three-quarters of a million pounds
and i don't know if anybody's seen a
report yet from the leisure facilities
how much of that is liable to this
council to pay for and how much
our current leisure contract is liable
to pay for
but what i would highlight is the fact
that our priority is the environment
center
for this council and there's been talk
of scratching around to find enough
money to buy the site that's here for it
whether we buy four and a half acres or
six
so before we jump and connect with all
of this huge amount of money
for a small council that's orange this
is a colossal
surplus and i was being said by david
about the
reasons for it but you know that's not
swinging over the measure part without
knowing exactly
how much of the figure that's in the
report here
715 000 the repairs to the
measured centers how much of that is
down to charging how much is down to
our contract
thank you i must admit
i have a degree of sympathy with
counselor leather there's also
the refurbishment of biddeford center
and the fact we can't meet
together on price for the acquisition of
property
there are other things hanging over our
heads
to see it just i'm
happy with the principle but to put all
this money
earmarked ring fence leisure
i think is a little bit dangerous when
we don't
know the true situation with pleasure
councillor james well i would say it's a
bit like
worrying about two houses when we're
probably about three or four hundred
sure
once we start dividing this money up we
may not provide anything
um so i would suggest that the report is
so
much it's charged in an issue that we've
gone
is that if we carry on with leisure
which is discretionary
but we need to have the funds to do it
um and we tackle the other problems as
we come to them
not to spend the money so thinly that we
achieve nothing
thank you chair steve uh chad
just had something so at volcano meeting
i think was it last week or the week
before and he made recommendations to
proceed with the the trade-in company
part of that report uh um
stipulated that we would bring back to
full council
with old business plan which outlines
the
the full costs of the leisure model
including the capital costs
so whilst we might bring fence this
money now it wouldn't necessarily
be spent until a further reward is
brought forward full council
in any case we'll be bringing reports
shortly
in terms of shock in terms of the
environmental center
so members will have an opportunity to
look at the
the two elements in the rooms before
anything is finally spent
okay
well i have a proposal and a second
there
put it to the vote those in favor please
share
that is unanimous
you see
does that bring me to the end of an
agenda
in record time almost
10 50. and i declare the